why don't you give me a few days Linnea
over by Christmas morning you're gonna
be calling me son
how many calling you dad don't think
that's gonna happen in the spirit of it
I have to know have you ever gone to
meet somebody's parents and they were
not a fan of you
not exactly definitely no fathers have
have disliked me like Brian's character
just like me in this movie uh there's
been a mother or two that just didn't
like me
I remember being very young throwing
pebbles at somebody's window and the
mother coming out and just like treating
me like a bunt let's get out of here you
scum and we became movie star James
Franco this is yeah I haven't been
throwing couples anybody spent any time
lately but um when I was the island I
was a young teenager I feel like layered
as a king the master of grand gestures
we have the tattoos we have the bowling
alley we have the doves what is the most
romantic thing that you've ever done to
win someone over gosh um I know I'm
pretty bad I've been pretty bad in the
romance department I think I think I'm a
caring guy but the grand gestures
I'm not great at no I need to put more
work into it all right so I you want
Stephen Colbert and you were saying that
you have to get married before your two
brothers who are already spoken for if
you're ever gonna walk down the aisle so
what are you looking for in about mine
two and a half months how do I win
Dave's wedding is he supposed to get
married in February I think I think he's
so casual about it he doesn't he's like
yeah I think in February are you playing
the bachelor party
si si I don't even think they do those
things I should do that
you